hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the last look demo now
this is a game that's gonna be coming
out later this year that's supposed to
be very scary and whatnot but this is a
demo so this is gonna show like um
things that demos show I don't need to
explain to you what a demo is do I so
let's get into the game why don't we
and also I loaded up the game to test
out some things and I saw this girl and
I didn't realize it at first but she's
standing next to her own portrait
wearing her exact same clothes like we
will see whether she'll make it stuff in
your office what the [ __ ] is McGarry oh
does it now I don't know I I can't
understand anything why do these horror
games always throw everything at you
just to confuse you were you listening
to that dialogue because holy [ __ ] I
can't believe how many open-ended set
like questions they said oh I can't
believe that thing let's talk about
Megerian oh you can't go in that place
oh god this girl's the sixth one what
the [ __ ] are you talking about sorry
anyway that's just a pet peeve of mine
when when things throw you in like it's
totally understandable that you don't
have all the pieces together but come on
be a little easy on me I dime
my brain very stupid can't handle this
okay anyway so tired the she plays noise
too it's okay listen how much stop time
has passed no I can't read this give me
the goddamn light without you I'm
nothing in numbers both dire from three
to six is there a clue here there's a
lot of really little writing in there
but I can't really read it with all this
light flickering over here oh don't run
it what whoa don't don't run it will
what does that say don't run it'll take
you drink oh there's like some night
blindness drink it will restore your
strength hide listen to the bells okay
listen oh I want to play who wants to
play
hello hi oh oh hi he dot me
dad me Alice Johnson my security card
uh-huh
luckily ha the [ __ ] okay so what does
that mean just girly stuff nothing
useful okay
so how did you get here and okay what
was this if I thought that browsing
through some dingy magazine would help
me out of unpleasant situations I would
already have a subscription well you
never know it could help and are those
my boobs wow what a wonderful first
person's prepared perfective this is I
have no intention of staying any longer
whether this is some kind of sick joke
or something worse okay so so what do we
do about it Oh like a bobby pin and the
girly stuff oh come on that's so that's
so obviously the thing well reach your
hand in there
well it probably is okay so anything
about these words and I just I couldn't
even tell that it was blood
dip did take crit take a dive oh yeah
that's good
yep yep that's good yeah
whoa alrighty then well I'm coded in
draw me something did you while you were
being grounded well that's perfectly
normal time to rationalize the situation
man it's awesome to have boobs I know I
don't want to put too much emphasis on
this but man I've always said if I had
boobs I would never get anything done
because I will be too busy playing with
them anyway okay so I got that open for
the axe
okay where would that be is that my
portrait again heed dad me is a picture
of me I didn't know something like that
existed sure maybe it's your alter ego
there was something hidden inside but I
can't seem to get out smash it then duh
oh well that was loud I just hope nobody
heard it oh okay sure
all right then Wow it's way too dog I
won't walk any further come on be brave
I do it listen to what your heart says
heart says run away fastly okay alright
then I need to find a flashlight or
something or else I'm not gonna go
anywhere
come on your dirty tricks won't work on
me I destroy myself day after day I hate
you leave me okay
ah I've worked with his assistant for
over a year now he's the lead of the
Department of astrophysics astrophysics
what does astrophysics has to do with
the horrifying mansion that's haunted
and stuff who's that I'll be with you in
a second she's in the accounting
department but we're a neat old ain't
that fascinating I think you're about to
talk now hello this looks warm and
inviting okay if I could use the
computer I might be able to contact the
police okay I don't know the password
most people use a password which is easy
to remember some important date or
something like that okay I don't know I
don't even know Krug II man how am I
gonna know Krug and be able to do this
okay um could just try 1 1 1 1
let's see the Solaris research and
technology centers temporarily closed
its gates since the beginning of fall at
least 3 employees have gone missing into
potentially victims of a crime the
latest person a young woman was last
seen a week ago since there seems to be
no other relationship between the
missing persons Solaris his reaction was
to send all employees on vacation we are
deeply troubled and we want to do
everything in our power to protect our
employees the police are still
investigating the case ok well that's
just as confusing as ever but at least
it gets something else who how about 2 0
1 3 there's a lot of numbers here I
wonder which one dates and stuff I don't
understand
uh-huh okay aah Oh 706 in bold you
wonder if that's it
Catherines birthday Oh 706 okay I got it
Oh 706 okay connection cannot be
established my picture is connection
good that be established two hundred
males your job I'm really sorry about
everything can't we talk about it one
last time I'm sick of it can you imagine
what you've done honestly I've never
seen so much of competence and lack of
responsibility before your fire bloody
hell I can't send an email [ __ ] bloody
hell okay so what about my dog hello mr.
Craven thank you for taking care of my
dog the next week please treat him like
that take him for a walk one full round
at 12 o'clock a.m. when you're back at
it should be 2 o'clock p.m.
ie we'll have a nap when it's 4:00 a.m.
these are some weird times that you're
putting up here afterwards around 6:00
you should feed them then you will need
to walk another big round till 4 o'clock
dog's name is safety that email didn't
make any goddamn sense at all ok then oh
wait serious attention whoring privacy
is overrated what's it what what is it
what is happening I can't why can't I
Mouse into here that doesn't make any
goddamn sense I can't Mouse in there
weird ok I guess I'm done then I can't
send any email oh it's so dark can I get
a flashlight please oh whoa hello hope
Cathy likes it trouble with the records
need to be fixed we'll be late again
need to call the babysitter again damn
this had to stop we'll take the day off
tomorrow should spend some time with
Cathy take her to the zoo Lisa's day of
death is next week need to think about
something forecast don't want her to be
a sad again six years and still ask
Isabelle for advice birthday party giant
cake organized trip to pony farm call
parents for sleepover permission
okey-dokey then
that's weird well then one of what else
am I here for Oh
this is dr. Carew's office uh-huh but it
can't be I don't know something went
very wrong I'm sorry
ah cool
all I had to do is turn on the light
mm-hmm
I think Cathy's his daughter
frickin douche
okay what happened we got there yeah
went over here
brats wait your dog I won't walk any
further oh that's some excuse for you
grow some balls strange clock out of
place huh and he's broken you can still
move for help okay so yeah damn that was
wrong what was wrong I didn't even do
anything
uh-huh damn okay all right so I I know
what this is this is in relation to that
weird email about the dog so if I look
at the dog again it's gonna tell me
times that's why I didn't make any sense
12 o'clock the dog's name is safety ah
okay so 12 2 4 6 then Walker Oh walking
one full around at 12:00 when you're
back it should be 2 o'clock oh okay
12 2 4 6 4 ok
damn what is that what's up buddy
tumbling whoo Oh what the [ __ ] was that
you want to tell me what the [ __ ] was
that
holy [ __ ] oh that might have been a bug
or something but it was unintentionally
the creepiest thing I've ever seen oh
man [ __ ] okay oh yeah one big round
that's right well two four six
okay sounds like I unlocked it indeed
emergency generator handle with care'
how about I punch it as hard as I can
while waiting for the weird hair to
float around my face safety emergency
generator online that's convenient what
did that do for me to turn the lights on
it didn't over here but maybe it did on
the other side maybe it did something
else in the office there and I'm just
running away from where I actually need
to go which would be totally stupid and
dumb and I shouldn't have done that I
bet there's nothing over here yep
there's none I made a big goofy error
cuz I'm a big dumb doofy Doo oh boy look
at me wandering the walls wasting
everybody's time I'm sorry oh hello what
are you a fuse of the end of the
hallways is missing oh I can think of
something maybe you could take I got
this feeling that the exit might be in
this exact direction yeah so if I take
it out of there I can put it in there
damn that was wrong damn damn damn damn
mmm
all right pretty [ __ ] I I think there is
someone on the way to this room there's
no exit what do we do
I you know I'm here yeah now you're
fired
your work was a disaster we're no longer
sustainable to the company oh and even
death of countless that remissions your
diffuser did not play okay
now you really think that the loss of
your work can be a justification maybe I
am NOT the most compassionate rainfall
they're not even a comeback you know I
gotta leave before
I have no more respectfully
okay whoa I'm actually in this I thought
this was a cutscene holy crap I can't
see much of anything oh this is
disorienting and sickening do you okay
then do it stop being such a doof and
just walk forward back into the realms
of the epileptics quit on acid gets
scared by the monster
alright hang on I have an idea let me
see where it drops me in to continue
okay so we're about to open the panel I
got the key I got the clock all done I
did the safety thing I pushed that I
believe I push there right just don't
you don't go okay is that butt donkey
doinked yeah that's been bit donkey
doing so I could open this because the
key apparently opens this panel and
we're going to do this think of
something I said I got this feeling that
the exit might be in this exact
direction boink boink then we're not
going to hide this time because we don't
want to run away we want to be brave
what was that
yeah holy [ __ ] oh no I think there is
someone on the way to this roof oh god
there's
exit I should hide okay maybe I won't do
that maybe I won't those that you're
gonna put some crackling in my ears and
then have some guy in a robe sprint at
me that was it open for more than that
oh I see and oh well that's all we got
for now so that is the end of the demo
thank you everybody so much for watching
I will probably play this one if fool
comes out and obviously you know I rag
down him for not giving me any of
information well it's just a demo they
would just want to get people intrigued
on it but it's just frustrating not to
know I'm but either way we'll get to the
mystery in a little bit so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other scary games that I played in
the description down below or in the
annotations over there and things again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye